this is a production of cornell
university you know thanks everyone for
for coming to the
second episode of the cornell turf show
this year yesterday was our first
episode on thursday uh where we had a
golf
turf focused webinar on fridays here for
our live audience at 10 a.m we'll be
doing a half an hour webinar and we'll
be alternating
every friday between sports turf and
lawn turf
um so this week is our sports turf
episode every week we'll kind of start
with frank ross
he will start us off with some timely
updates on the growing season and then
we'll transition into an introduction
for our guest uh this week we're talking
about sports fields and our guest is
chris sitko
former graduate student here at cornell
and currently works at the
martha's vineyard the vineyard club golf
course at their organic golf course on
the vineyard
but had a lot of experience with sports
field monitoring safety
while at cornell doing many things as a
graduate student
so we're excited to get to uh our
conversation a little bit but
frank if you want to start us off um
what are we looking at here early in the
season
well we're looking at 24 minutes to be
the fastest 30 minutes in
turf carol so i'm gonna get right to it
brother and
just use this picture to demonstrate
sort of what a lot of guys
are hearing you know with the pent-up
demand
and opening back up of society i can
tell you personally i
you know did some traveling across the
country this past week and and i can
tell you that the rest of the world
or the rest of this country um uh is
opening up
uh rapidly and and that's going to play
out in the use of our sports fields
moving forward and so
uh just to remind you you know we
started these things last year
as a way of dealing with my anxiety
i think and partially be because we
wanted to find ways to support you guys
out there in the field while things were
very unsure
we were able to contribute with some
education it went over pretty well
uh and so we're returning again for a
10-week run
uh this spring and we'll do this with
you sports folks
every other week so uh again let me
start out with the way we ended last
year
the way we were doing it last year is we
want to keep you safe we want to make
sure your workers are safe
and of course there's all kinds of
protocols in place that'll probably stay
in place even after
we're all vaccinated you can imagine
some of the cleaning and disinfecting
things
will probably continue you wonder how
this you know it came up
quickly you wonder how how it's going to
go away and how we're going to return to
interacting with each other but
certainly in the workplace
we're going to face some challenges
there but the bigger safety question
that we're going to take up
with uh my colleague the environmental
asset
and research manager at the vineyard
golf club is you know are your athletes
playing on a safe field right you know
is that what your field is looking like
uh coming out of the winter that would
be bad considering that most people
didn't have their fields
used much last year a lot of the
activities that uh are used for
active field use you know active
recreation
organized sports round ball sports
baseball things like that
was pretty much closed uh to a lot of
people during
during the during the pandemic and for a
lot of the year
and if it was used it wasn't used that
intensively and so i'll
take a picture back that we had from
last year and boy you know
you probably if you if you took
advantage last year you should have
as dense and and a turf cover that
you've ever had
if you were able to get the resources
out there uh
in a timely fashion without traffic you
know i'm wondering if people created any
thatch
problems uh because obviously excessive
nitrogen without
uh much wear could lead to thatch but at
the same time
you know i'm staring down the barrel of
what a lot of people are
you know people are out there using
their fields so this is the text message
i got from the
soccer coach yesterday just yesterday at
cornell and mcgovern is the training
grounds
uh that our cornell soccer team plays on
so you know i received this question
because we've we've been involved with
the soccer program and chris has been
integratedly
intimately involved with that while he
was here at cornell is going to talk a
little bit about
some of the things we learned while he
was here and i'll just start out as carl
said talking about the weather
um just you know it's it was a warmer
than normal winter
i don't think not everybody felt that
uh but it certainly was uh warmer than
normal uh throughout the northeastern
united states with very few
cooler than normal periods if you just
take the december
to february period now snowfall was a
little bit different we had a good
amount of snowfall in december
january was record dry and and february
again brought a fair amount of snowfall
across the united states as well as uh
in the northeast and
and a lot of it fell to the east a lot
of the snowfall
fell uh to the east of the region not so
much
even where we are up here now you look
at our current soil temperatures right
we're going to govern our ability to
grow and put up with traffic
by how much the system is functioning
well you know the system is is barely
functioning if at all i mean you're
barely creeping into the 50s at the 2
inch soil
at the 2 inch depth now that's not to
say you can't get warmer at the surface
uh but certainly what you might start
the year out with
uh is light surface rolling you know
before they get out there
maybe put a light roll on the fields you
obviously want to watch out for
compaction but there probably was some
heaving
and frost that occurred uh through this
through the winter time and
you know if you're on a top dressing
program this certainly will go
very well but certainly light rolling
you know i'm not suggesting you know you
take the 10 ton vibratory street roller
out there
but just a light firming of the surface
could be
useful because you know obviously these
are the kinds of conditions
that we're trying to avoid occurring if
you start to use these fields under
conditions at the top where they're
still a little wet and even maybe frozen
you can really wear out the surface
particularly as the
you know the tur the soil itself might
be prone to compaction
now as we look to the current conditions
right our normal march you know up until
10 years ago
our normal average march temperatures
you can see
are still fairly cool this is average
temperature
and that's not to say it doesn't get
warmer than this and
and that you can't creep into the 50s
and 60s like we just did
for the last few days but just a
reminder that in general
the uh you know the temperatures are
cooler and i think up here in upstate
new york
we're going to be in the teens again uh
relatively quickly now
you know what does this mean for how
grass grows uh it generally
means that well you might have a few
days where the potential for growth is
at 80 percent right you know the
potential for growth not that it
actually grows that much
but because of temperature which is
driving the photosynthetic apparatus
and if you're getting light to the
surface you have the potential to grow
now if you'll grow
is a different story but in the next few
weeks if weeks if we start to get to our
average temperatures
we're going to be at about 20 potential
growth so even if it was growing as
much as it could it would only be about
20
of optimum growth which again if you're
putting traffic on it
is going to be quite a problem now chris
is going to talk a lot more about this
in a second
but certainly covers and darkening
agents that warm the soil
stimulate some growth and recovery can
be very useful at these times
targeting areas with tarps uh
permeable or impermeable preferably
to let light and water through can
really accelerate that growth in an area
where you
might otherwise still be dormant and not
ready to take on
so much growth so the question to
for us for the rest of the time today is
are your athletes playing on a safe
field
well just before i you know introduce
chris
you know we have one of still the best
websites available that my colleague
joanne grudadorio led many years ago
in developing is still one of the few
that's as comprehensively focused on
producing safe sports fields and it's in
desperate need of a
of an update so we're hoping that over
the next several years we'll be able to
get some updated information here
but obviously investing in safe sports
fields as we talked about last year
during the pandemic
communication is a very important part
of that so what do you want to tell the
people
the coaches and athletic directors who
are texting you and pressing you
to get out onto those fields now you
know in an ideal world where we weren't
living in the middle of a pandemic
right we could have a reasonable
conversation
on the impact of overuse of on field
quality and safety right
now if you're an athletic director and a
coach you know they want good feels and
fit in all their practice and games
and you know they want to keep their
schedule and now kids
you know mental health is saying we got
to get these kids outside
we got to get these kids active
especially at the youth level but
everybody wants to be out and organized
sports has been such an important
component
of many of these uh people's interaction
with the natural world it's some of the
only time they get outside
is to do these things but it does have a
cost at this time of the year and
i'm not saying don't let them use it i'm
just saying make sure you have a
conversation with them about it
and try to keep it safe so on the sports
field website you'll see
these calendars that joanne developed
many years ago
uh to look at here's a spring in fall
sports with minimal management we did
low medium and high
budgets we did spring fall and
year-round use
and i just pulled out a couple here and
you can see
you know if you're under a minimal
management condition
right you know we're already telling you
to start seeding perennial ryegrass
if you can't cultivate if you can't top
dress
this increases the likelihood of injury
and excessive surface hardness
so if you look at a year-round
management plan with
you know high-end management look at
what we're saying
you know monitor routing depth solid
time cultivation
lightly roll seed perennial rye so
there's a lot of things
if you're able to get the resources to
get your sports feels going whether
it's covering or doing these other
things um
i think it's critical to start having
those conversations
now uh chris as i as i trans uh
transfer to you and introduce you
you know you had some really hands-on
experience interacting both with the
natural surfaces here
and the synthetic surfaces as we've
carved out this partnership with
cornell athletics so thanks for that
congratulations on your new gig and
congratulations on your
pending uh marriage which was just
announced everybody it's on the uh you
know front page of the
paper now uh and the vineyard right news
is slow out there
let's talk a little bit as we enter into
this when i asked a question
safe i know you've got a few slides you
want to show why don't you start with
that number two slide
when we say safe there's actually a way
we can quantify it
so why don't you start talking about the
way you approach this as we've
approached it from a data perspective
yeah carl and frank first thanks for
having me on uh always always great to
chat about grass and let me see if i can
get myself up here even though you're in
the golf business now
that's right
yeah we'll jump to number two yeah it's
a you know it's just one aspect of
everything that has become data driven
uh across the board for managing fields
you know whether it's your fertility or
you know the varieties you're stitching
in and or even calculating field use i
i think there's a lot of beneficial data
that
needs to be incorporated in in how we
manage and how we use the fields but
the two i mean the two we focus on and i
think you know it's probably the two
most popular or
easy you know i'd say maybe easiest to
to
you know gather is the surface hardness
which you've
you've mentioned a few times already and
then you know so that would be the clegg
device
uh the red device on the left and that's
essentially you know you're dropping
a missile and it's it's measuring like
how far
it's penetrating that surface so with
the cleg you're using multiple drops
and then it's the third drop that you're
actually using the number for
the second device is the tomashir from
turf tech this is actually what we
started with but we've moved on to their
shear vein but essentially what you're
trying to measure
is traction you know the shear
resistance of that surface and
you know one aspect that i think we've
talked about a lot in the past you know
just bringing synthetic into it
natural natural grass has the ability to
dip it you know
you don't necessarily see divots on
since that synthetic turf
you know i'm not saying you know i don't
want to get too far into the
the safety components right off the bat
but you know just that surface being
able to
to give but give you enough traction
where you can perform to the level that
you need
and that's going to vary a lot you know
whether you're looking at elementary
school
level kids or you know what we did at
cornell with you know division one
athletes so and then lastly
you know the picture in the background
you made a great point which i didn't
really think about
if you didn't have a uh you know use in
the fall i hope everybody's coming out
of winter you know
you and you know if you're buried in
snow maybe hopefully you don't have too
many disease issues but
hopefully we have a dense surface and i
think that's the key to
you know safety you know we can take all
the values we want but if
i think the number one thing that you
have to focus on is just keeping
keeping a dense turf um which is going
to you know provide that
that interface between the player and
the soil
and you already brought up the cornell
turf website but this is right off that
safe
sports fields website and this is you
know we're talking about soil so
in the spring i think most people are
going to have saturated conditions
so knowing your soil type on your fields
whether they were
constructed with native soil or you know
maybe you had the
sort of benefit of having a sand based
system is gonna is gonna mean a lot to
you know to your point if the coach is
asking can i get out there well if
there's puddles i'd you know
the quickest answer is no but
understanding why you might have puddles
is another question
and you know to your point about
communication you have to communicate
with
the stakeholders often who aren't the
grass growers you know so
nobody likes to spend money and bury it
in the ground but you know good drainage
is critical
to having a safe field
and then just moving on you know what
can you do or you know over time
especially
to you know amend that surface or you
know make it playable
during these you know you know early
spring where mother nature isn't
friendly
so top dressing you know sand top
dressing is a popular
uh management practice and but
understand what it's doing
and you know be sure if you are doing it
and spending that money and investing in
sand
make sure your your stakeholders
understand you know so
if you've been on a top dressing program
and you've accumulated
let's say a little you know a couple
inches at the surface
take a core take a picture you know the
field down the road
might not have this but you know and it
might not be usable you know so make
sure you highlight these
these investments you've made over time
and you already brought up the rolling
frank but
i think it's a you know it's it's kind
of a do no harm time you know i don't i
think everybody's biting at the bit to
get out there and do something
but understanding your soils especially
if you have a native clay
you got to be careful getting out there
with a roller uh to avoid too much
compaction
and you had already brought up the
covers i think your net you already
showed the next picture but
cornell this is what this was actually
in the fall so we were trying to extend
our growing season versus you know
started up early but we just focused on
on the heavy use area so we're looking
at
you know the gold mouth and i think we
had maybe two more games after this
so i mean one note with the covers we
were blessed i mean
so cornell has a separate game field so
we were able to
you know get the tarp out and we left it
down for almost an entire week so
you know if you have a field that is
practice and games and
you know it's used every day you might
have not quite have the flexibility
to use you know these types of tools to
you know
kind of get that growth to either
continue later
yeah but a dark top dressing will work
right a dark top dressing
will also work there yeah absolutely and
you know it's funny
you know i'm on twitter and follow all
the golf guys now but
folks like in the mountain west you know
they're they're top dressing with black
sand dark
sand all the time and it it it heats the
surface
anything to heat that surface and you
know kind of accelerate
uh the system um but yeah so this is the
you know post cover
for after just a week you know you see
it you're seeing that that difference in
the color
you know maybe we had a little bit of
growth we didn't measure clippings or
anything but
i would assume that you know we had a
little bit more growth especially if
you're putting seed down
you know you might get a little more
germination in colder colder temps
this is just so we buried soiled uh
thermocon uh temperature loggers and
this is just a graph of you know
what was under that cover so this was
you know second half of october
and you know it might not look like much
so the blue line is
uh for that but i don't know if
everybody's uh
if people just have audio or if they're
tuning in on the stream but
so what we did we remem we measured the
soil temperature at two at two inch
depth
and this is just under the cover and
then we put one in the ground at the
same depth
not under a cover and right off the bat
there's hardly any difference but you
see towards the end of that seven day
period
you know a few degrees here and there
and you know it's one thing that you
look back it's like oh i wish we would
have put one at one inch or maybe one at
the surface
because then i think you know we'd
really start to see these larger
differences that
you know might give you a little bit
better inclination than just the dark
green uh picture because
you know i think at the biggest
difference we might have a five degree
difference but we're at two inch soil
depth you know that that
i think that means something so at the
surface you're gonna have a much larger
difference
and then you know we can't we can't
forget about synthetics i you know your
first picture was awesome
you know guys on the field so
and you know i i that last year i was
there i you know the cornell guys i
think they plowed
shulk off 20 times and but you know to
if you are plowing your synthetic
surfaces to try to open them up
make sure you're doing that in a careful
manner you know you could be possibly
moving that info around and i think the
easiest way to check is
you know oftentimes in the snow piles
we'd see the
your infill you know that whether it's
the black crown rubber you know a little
bit of sand
so you know that could be your first
indication that you got to get out there
and check the infill depth
because you know when we're thinking
about you know sheer resistance and
back to the hardness on these surfaces
at least on the synthetics i think
you know having that desired infill
depth is absolutely key
to having consistent you know the
consistent readings and the safe
readings
yeah and i think you know just to
reinforce that chris
that infill depth is a relatively easy
thing to measure that tells you a lot
about safety once
andy mcnittan the penn state guys did
that work
showing the value of the volume of
infill is changing
everything um i i think
you know that's what it's it's we're
always looking for an easy way to take
this data
you know if you can't afford the clag
you don't want to look at rotational
traction and
you know what do they actually mean they
mean more to you as a manager
obviously you don't want the kid's head
to crack open on it so let's get to the
hardness of these things moving forward
yeah no and i mean we got ours it was
changing contracting without you know
servicing the field and
you know we were just talking with them
and they threw us a little i wish i had
a picture
you know it's a little device it just
you know sinks down into that carpet
and it gives you the infill depth i mean
it's really easy five minutes you walk
around
take a couple spots i would like you to
you know i would think you know maybe
focus on
if you are using the fields or you know
maybe the last uh team to use the field
so you know cornell's baseball field
is it has a synthetic surface and we see
right around the bases where
you know folks are sliding i don't know
if everybody can see my cursor but
kind of back here you you almost see all
that info right at the surface
whereas near the base you're almost down
to the mat
underneath so you know that just
even you can do this with a broom too i
don't think you need anything anything
fancy it's just a matter if you have a
little infill or brushing this back to
where it needs to go
same thing with the lacrosse gold mount
so i don't yet to your point you don't
need fancy equipment a little
time you know cheap measuring device
maybe
and but it's you know one aspect that
you know synthetic turf it still needs
maintenance
uh even coming out of winter and you
know getting ready for a season
oh cross i just saw your pull uh but let
me see if i know yeah
you know i think it was good chris as we
were talking about um
you know less expensive ways to measure
field safety you know we talk about the
clegg and the traction device
those can be a little bit expensive for
certain people uh just asking people if
they take measures of field safety so it
looks like about two-thirds do
a third don't but you know i think that
just reinforces your point there's some
easy cheap ways you can go out and
and i know i know i know we're getting
short on time i don't know but but i
want to say this
because i think what you're doing as you
wrap up here and i'll you know tie it up
at the end
this would be a good place uh it's
unusual number one
i'm in any audience of sports turf
managers
where any more than 10 of them actually
take field measures so we've got a
unique collection of high-end people
measuring those things here number two
and i think chris you've done it well
here is you have
people's attention uh focused on the
fields you had to plow them off
you know they're active to get out there
the way you can
talk to them about the soil say yeah we
got this problem now
and you see it how about we fix it
moving forward we can go ahead and use
it
do it you know whatever's got to be done
maybe even you take a field and
sacrifice it
but but in the future you've got their
attention how
how do you communicate it to them moving
forward so i don't that's where i want
to reinforce what you said
now now get us through this real big
safety concern
yeah uh so this is you know this was
from 2019
and you know it was one of those things
it's like the lacrosse teams are using
the field and
you know we ask you frank well should we
be testing he's like yeah of course
you're like yes
they're using it or isn't it um so this
is
you know mid-february to mid-march which
you know we're towards the tail end of
this but
you know this is very relevant and it's
you know i think the temperatures were
much colder than
you know maybe you're getting now but so
the
the blue line is tracking just average
daily temperature
and then the precipitation is on the on
the right side right vertical axis
and then the bold numbers at the top are
our clay or our surface hardness
measurements
just for reference the nfl sets a
threshold at 100
you know for for that field to be you
know safe and playable
so right off the bat we get out there
and we get a 152 you know it's like holy
smokes
and you know we walk over to the asphalt
around it you know it's like
yeah it's like oh my goodness you know
it's it's frozen salad
you know and i think all of us it's like
well you know the reason they're on the
synthetic turf is because you can use it
all year
and you know i don't think you need uh
necessarily a clay to
you know that surface was really hard
you could take the whole coach's head
and bang his head on it and see if it's
hard enough
you know and it's something you know
it's one of those complaints everybody
complains about all the infill getting
in their kids socks and shoes
and you know if you take your hand and
just rub the surface you can see it kind
of scattered
well in this connected scenario when it
was frozen i mean
nothing was moving i mean it was locked
up but then
you look at two days later we get a
surge in temperature a little bit of
you know rain that system falls out
we're right back down to 100.
you know so the variability in in this
is is pretty drastic
and then you know even further down the
month we're about you know
huge you know this is average
temperature so for down near 10 you know
the
you know the low for that was you know
probably zero so and again
uh you know maybe you have maybe
moisture plays into it you know if you
have a little bit of precipitation
and then you have a real drastic drop in
temperature
you know even you know even a synthetic
field can freeze
you know which something i never
considered i don't think any of us
really considered it i always thought
they were you know
all season long um so just you know
be cautious you know even on a synthetic
field you know just go out there rub
your hand
i think that would be the easiest thing
if you don't have a way of measuring how
even how it feels under foot bounce a
ball you know i think there's a lot of
you know just less
you know fancy ways to determine this
you know how hard that field might be
perfect you're good
i'll just end with this like yeah it's
been a long winter
you know you know work the kinks out
yeah
whether it's you know mowing a straight
line or painting a straight line
brings the time to work the king sound i
just love when this happens at cornell
where we're supposed to know what we're
doing right
i mean i i think it's a measure of you
know every operation
has its challenges and for us you know
like i'm already staring
at a another text from the coach
clarifying exactly how they can use the
field so
um listen chris thanks for taking the
time carl
we're pretty close to the witching hour
here brother um
i i think we what we want to do is
promote a continued conversation so
maybe
if people have additional questions
about this or other things we can start
off the show next week
with taking some questions and some
comments uh
uh and and have chris back at some point
too
uh to to continue to inform folks about
this
chris thanks for taking the time to join
us oh you ready to get us out of here
yeah uh thanks again chris and frank
like you're saying uh
questions you know we got our live
attendees and we got some
questions through the q a um but if
you're watching either on
uh youtube after the fact or podcast and
you've got a question
either about this week's episode or
maybe um for our future guests
just send us an email uh you can send me
an email css223
cornell.edu you've got any questions or
you can reach us on twitter too that's a
great place to
post a link for any questions um thanks
everyone
for joining us for episode 2 2021 season
the cornell turf show
fastest 30 minutes in turn maybe
slightly more today you know sometimes
we have technical difficulties i'm a
millennial but i'm not immune to
the digital uh difficulties so uh thanks
everyone again
the live attendees and yeah hope uh
we'll see you soon
yeah thanks a lot see you guys see chris
see you take care
you guys this has been a production of
cornell university
on the web at cornell.edu